es un buen momento para hacer otro
ejemplo acerca de ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden no
homogéneas pero esta vez voy a cambiar
de nuevo la parte no homogénea sin
embargo la parte que es homogénea la voy
a dejar igual para no confundirlos ni
entrar en más detalles
va a ser mi prima -3 de prima menos 4 y
diestro lo voy a igualar a otra parte
que no va a ser esta vez exponenciales
no va a ser esta vez trigonométricas va
a ser un polinomio de x 4 x cuadrado muy
bien ahora cómo se resolverá esto pues
si nosotros nos acordamos si tendríamos
una exponencial proponíamos como
solución algo que tenía que ver con
exponencial si nosotros teníamos una
trigonométricas pues proponíamos algo
que tenía que ver con trigonométricas
pues en esta ocasión tenemos un
polinomio y adivinan que voy a poner
como solución particular
pues si un socio en particular va a ser
una
un polinomio pero este polinomio base de
grado 2 no tiene sentido que sea de un
grado más grande entonces voy a suponer
que mi polinomio es a x cuadrada y x
cuadrada porque en mi polinomio del otro
lado de mi ecuación diferencial es de
grado 2 ya esto le voy a sumar 10 veces
x y a esto le voy a sumar se tiene tanto
el término de x cuadrada como el de x
como el de c bien pues vamos a derivar
lo como siempre hemos hecho la derivada
de esto es 2a x + b y si nosotros
hacemos la tercera derivada entre 1 la
segunda derivada es simplemente 2a
recuerden que aquí la parte pesada es no
equivocarse yo ya me equivoqué y parece
que estoy un poco dormido pero no sé si
bien ahora sustituyamos me queda 2 a
menos 3 veces la primera derivada o sea
menos 3 más menos 3 no es menos 6
dos por tres en 66 a x menos 3 ve bien
parece ser cayéndose cometiendo errores
menos cuatro veces pues la función
original o sea menos 4a x cuadrada menos
4 b x menos 46 y esto tiene que ser
igual pues a la parte que está del otro
lado o sea a 4x cuadrado bien lo primero
que quiero hacer es agrupar términos
semejantes entonces me voy a aplicar
primero en voy a cambiar el color para
que todo sea más claro bien aquí es lo
único que tiene que ver con x cuadrada o
sea me queda menos 4a
x cuadrada ahora apuntemos los que
tienen que ver con x que es menos 6 a x
menos 4 x lo voy a apuntar en uno solo
entonces me queda más menos 6 a menos 4
b todo esto por x bien y ahora lo que no
tiene que ver ni con x cuadrada ni con x
normal o sea 2 a menos 3 b menos 4 cm
entonces escribí de todos a menos 3 b -
4 c secas y esto tiene que ser igual a 4
x cuadrado bien pongamos otro colador y
me va a quedar igual a 4 x cuadrada
perfecto al menos tenemos una sopa de
colores y una sopa de colores que ya me
dio la solución porque fíjense que menos
4 x cuadrada tiene que ser igual a 4 x
cuadrada y por otra parte menos 6 menos
4 b pues tiene que ser igual a lo que
está del otro lado de x pero pues es 0 x
porque no había nada de x
y de manera análoga +0 porque pues dos a
menos tres venenos cuatro se tiene que
ser igual a cero no había nada que no
fuera ex cuadrado bien pues ahora sí a
despejar menos cuatro a tiene que ser
igual a cuatro o dicho de otra manera
igual a cuatro muy bien o dicho de otra
manera pues vale menos uno pues yo paso
al menos cuatro el otro lado dividiendo
pues me quedan menos 1
ya sabemos que avale menos 1 y de hecho
aquí la voy a ocupar porque menos 6 a
menos 4 b es igual a cero entonces de
una vez voy a sustituir a aa porque a
vale menos uno y si yo lo pongo aquí
pues me quedan menos por menos me da más
y seis por unas 6
y 6-4 esto tiene que ser igual a 0
habíamos quedado que era la otra parte o
sea 0 y de hecho aquí ya puede despejar
a b 4 b es lo mismo que 6 pasó el 4 b
del otro lado
entonces me queda solamente 6 y b es
igual a 6 entre 4 o sea 3 medios muy
bien ya se mueve entonces tengo 2 a
menos 3 b menos 4 c de una vez ya puedo
despejar hacer voy a meter los valores
de a entonces me quedan menos 2 menos
tres volver pero b vale tres medios
entonces me quedan menos nueve medios
menos 4 cm y esto tiene que ser igual a
cero bien para no equivocarme como la
vez pasada vamos haciéndolo con mucho
cuidado esto es menos 4 menos 9 todo
sobre 2 porque pues dos son cuatro
medios y muy bien y esto tengo que
restar cuatro siempre lo voy a pasar a
través del otro lado me queda 4 c
bien menos 49 menos 13 medios entonces
me queda que 4 cm es igualdad menos 13
medios menos 13 medios es igual a 4 cm y
siguió paso el 4 dividiendo o dicho de
otra manera debido a ambas partes entre
4 pues ya tengo el valor de ser se va a
ser ni más ni menos que menos 13 octavos
muy bien ya tengo ya tengo ave ya tengo
6 james ya lo logré
no me equivoqué está en cuenta no tengo
ningún error hasta ahorita entonces si
ya tengo al ave y hace que eran los
coeficientes indeterminados
recuerden que así se llama el vídeo
recuerden que así se llama la forma de
resolverlo entonces yo ya puedo
sustituir en mi en y que en mi solución
particular que quien va a ser pues a x
cuadrada o sea menos x cuadrada más bx
pero verá tres medios sea más tres
medios de x
pero se vale menos trece octavos y
recuerden que ya pasamos la parte
difícil que era no equivocarnos en cosas
de álgebra entonces como ya no me
equivoqué pues ahora voy a buscar la
solución de la parte homogénea de la
ecuación diferencial homogénea asociada
a esta ecuación diferencial no homogénea
que era yeví prima menos 3 y prima menos
4 y igual a 0 y nosotros en varios
vídeos pasados ya habíamos visto la
solución homogénea de esta ecuación si
se acuerdan era una constante que
multiplicaba a la 4x porque 4 era una
raíz más una segunda constante por la
menos x porque menos 1 era otra raíz
bien si ya tengo las soluciones entonces
lo único que resta es recordar que si
nosotros sumamos la solución particular
y la solución general de la homogénea
entonces ya tengo la solución general de
mi ecuación diferencial de segundo orden
no homogénea entonces pues no resta más
que esta parte de aquí sumarle estos de
acá vamos a sumar sólo de una vez
más se 1 a la 4 x + c 2
a la menos x y aquí lo tiene usted esta
es la solución general de la ecuación
diferencial no homogénea que no fue tan
doloroso o al menos lo más doloroso ya
pasó que fue no equivocarnos en las
cosas de álgebra que hicimos en los
procedimientos anteriores y nos dio así
una respuesta super coquetas no pueden
decir que no las respuestas de la
ecuación diferencial del segundo orden
no homogéneo así que nos vemos en el
siguiente